how are you hedging your bets to
profit and survive that uh economic and
change in the world that you see coming
it goes right back to commodities
because in that world where you know one
of their main things obviously is
climate change
and uh i'm not someone that's going to
say that climate change is right or
wrong or man-made or not man-made you
know your audience can decide themselves
let's just agree on that yeah but but i
can uh i can tell you that the global
elite don't care about polar bears right
they don't care about the temperature in
the ocean it's all just a ruse it's a
trojan horse to help them
achieve those malthusian objectives
and the power control and wealth and
then we go back to the kissinger quote
you know how do you control countries
will you control the energy and how do
you control the population you control
the food and we can see that kind of
play out with all the food shortages and
energy prices going sky high
and then with them again controlling
that narrative which i think they're
going to do more and more through this
quote unquote disinformation
and this
this basically war on freedom of speech
and this push towards censorship but
that's you know kind of a completely
separate topic but if you look at um you
know how they're trying to get from a to
b
with the green new deal as an example
with trying to completely uh
stop using fossil fuels which goes right
back to lead remember and the whole esg
movement well why is it that you know
why is or one of the reasons i'll say
not the entire reason but one of the
main reasons why
energy prices are so high today is
because of the esg movement because no
capital went into sourcing more supply
so sure you can sit there and say how
dirty coal is and sure you can sit there
and say how we shouldn't invest in
natural gas and then you can sleep well
at night you can look yourself in the
mirror and pat yourself on the back
thinking that you're doing good
but at the end of the day that's going
to mean much much much higher prices
and that's going to mean that the the
poor and the middle class suffer
to a greater degree and that means lower
gdp growth and that means that the
standard of living for society goes down
because energy is the economy if you
looked at a
a chart rich of the uh global population
you'll see it just kind of exponential
growth like that but if you can if you
put that up against a chart with gdp gdp
does the same thing but do that with
energy use and energy does the exact
same thing so if you don't have that
energy increasing at the same rate you
cannot increase gdp and that's going to
lower the standard of living but my
point there is everything that they're
pushing as far as their narrative is
going to lead to higher and higher
commodity prices not just with energy
coal uranium is another thing that i
really really like right now but it's
also going to lead to the
soft commodities increasing in price
because unfortunately we're going to see
massive shortages i look at what's
happening in sri lanka right now you
know their their government is
completely imploding because they can't
get diesel
you know they just cannot get fuel
because they don't have the dollars
because for a variety of different
reasons but i think that's going to get
a lot better uh before or excuse me
that's going to get a lot worse before
it gets better so if you want an
investment theme around the great reset
agenda it would be buy commodities but
maybe not now you know wait till there's
panic wait till the price really goes
down and use that as a buying
opportunity for this uh what i think
will contribute to this long-term super
cycle what are the commodities that you
like the best you talked about uranium
coal
yeah the two those are the two i like
the best coal and uranium and you like
uranium for the purpose of nuclear power
plants
yeah because i think that's going to be
their only option uh and you can already
see that your only option like i find
it's funny when you see these like uh
guys that think that you know electric
cars are the solution and they think
that there's like
fields of windmills and solar panels
that are that are collecting the
electricity to charge up these cars but
they don't realize like probably 95 of
the electricity comes from coal and
whatever nuclear plants are still
running but i think there's a lot of
people that are afraid of
nuclear still although you're right it's
it's really the only prudent source of
uh hardcore reliable energy that's
that's relatively cheap and safe even
though yeah ironically enough it's a lot
it's like greener than uh something like
natural gas or something that we've
tried to replace it biomass has been a
big one that's been blowing up over the
last few years which is really just
cutting down forests and burning the
wood
yeah
they call it biomass to make it sound
environmentally friendly but it's it's
just you know tearing down trees and
burning them yeah one of the charts i've
used to illustrate what we've been
discussing
uh quite extensively is a chart of
energy use broken down by the specific
energy source going back to like 1800
and it that exponential like we said but
you know back in 1800 like the number
one source probably 99 percent of our
fuel came from uh biofuels to your point
it was either lumber or dried cow dung
really
and then we went to oil petroleum then
we go to cold and natural gas
then wind solar and and nuclear but what
you'll notice is that we never use less
of the prior energy source
so said another way
today in 2022
we are using more biofuel than we did in
the year 1800
when it was uh you know 100 pretty much
of the energy we used we we don't use
less of it we just use more and more and
more which allows the economy to grow
and allows the standard of living to
increase so those people that say that
we need to replace oil with solar you
don't know what you're talking about we
don't need to replace things we need to
make sure that our energy sources
continue to grow exponentially if we
don't have that then what you're going
to have is just uh you're going to kill
billions of people on earth and you're
going to lower the standard of living
for everyone else and it's it's going to
get really ugly really quick if you if
you flatten out the energy source but
yet keep the uh
population growing exponentially they've
got the you know that's one thing i'll
give them credit for like bill gates and
klaus they've got the problem correct
it's just their solution is wildly
wildly wrong you know
my solution would be let the free market
fix this it's been fixing it since
malthus came out with his ideas in 1800
because if the population goes from 7
billion to 9 billion what bill gates
forgets to tell you is that's an
additional 2 billion people on this
planet that can solve the problem
and if you just deregulate if you just
let the people uh you know just do what
they do and and pursue their own
self-interest
going back to atlas shrugged you're
going to solve these malthusian problems
but it's not going to come from a
top-down approach it's got to be from a
decentralized bottom-up free-market
capitalist approach
yeah but i mean you're asking these
elites to step aside and let the markets
do their thing and they don't like doing
that yeah yeah they're always going to
try to meddle it crushes their world
view because their worldview
is based pretty much in eugenics
with this idea that they are
superior in pretty much every way so if
they can't solve the problem there's no
way they can expect anyone else to solve
the problem because everyone else is
inferior to them
yeah and i think it all you know is
predicated on breeding fear whether it's
you know fear around the environment
climate change
food you know
look at viruses
they're doing to the free-range chickens
in in uh the united have you read into
that i mean that is very disturbing
they're they're killing them by the
millions
because they're saying that they're
scared of another you know bird flu and
that it's like really are you really
scared of that are you just trying to
make sure people can't feed themselves
i don't hear about the new one that just
came out it's called the monkey pox
oh i i heard about that this morning
somewhere yeah that's that's you guys
are gonna be hearing a lot about that
over the next few weeks because uh the
whole uh cerveza sickness has uh played
itself out and you know people aren't
aren't really buying it anymore so they
have to cook up a new one yeah um i
don't know um back to the commodities
with coal and uranium are there any
companies that you like i have my pen
ready so i can jot down and add it to my
watch list
[Laughter]
no you know i i need to get back on that
bandwagon i've been so busy that back in
march of 2020
i i was i wanted to buy these things so
i bought just the etfs because i didn't
have time to research it so i bought ura
which is an etf for uranium
and i bought the coal etf which at the
time was kol
and it was paying like some outrageous
dividend yield like 15 so
uh with coal what happened is it it like
tripled or quadrupled in price
but for some reason it was so unpopular
that uh they they
they stopped it they they just
discontinued the etf and that's a great
contrarian indicator in and of itself
right there
but now i'm looking for some other coal
plays when uh they come down but i don't
have any specific ones i would look at
producers
maybe in the united states but
i hate to say australia usually those
are the ones that pay the great
dividends but i think people just have
to do some homework there
also if you want to if you guys want to
follow chris mcintosh on twitter
he's at capitalist exploits i believe is
his handle
he's one of the people i partner with in
rebel capitalist pro
and he's been a hedge fund
manager for over 20 years and he is
really neck deep in the commodity space
especially with coal and uranium and uh
you know he has a lot of those specific
companies that he suggests as far as
uranium though i can give you a good one
there
and that would just be the sprott
uh uranium trust and what's interesting
is usually
if you want to go long uranium you've
got to go through a producer but you're
taking on additional risk there because
you've got a management team you've got
a capital structure
you've got
you know you've got the the risk of
whatever country
the uranium producer maybe they
nationalize the mine who knows what
happens
you've got government risk there as well
but if you can actually buy the
commodity itself then you eliminate all
that risk that's the pure play you go
long uranium prior to sprott setting up
this trust that wasn't possible but now
it is you just buy shares of their trust
and what they do is they actually buy
the physical uranium and they store it
so you don't have to store a radioactive
product yeah in your garage next to your
mclaren 720.
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you